walk him to this video playing Grand
Master for weed favorite Seabiscuit 2003
mysterious it's a winner account I never
played him though okay let's see [ __ ]
again let's let's play this line my
score is not so bad with it so why not
stick to it okay well this erm i
actually like for white
I mean not that I had been expert but
what I was seeing about this it seemed
quite okay maybe here black shouldn't
take on d5 but maybe castles yeah this
this should be joint quite comfortable
position really maybe maybe I caught him
underwear so it's some somehow okay
maybe maybe black has officially 6 cm or
something sometimes you can play that
this should be six queen bee seven and
takes on d2 and short castles this kind
of weird stuff yeah yeah white the white
as white always has this kind of cop out
with Bishop c3 and I'm doing that
compared to online that I know I have
the H form of extra and this is in fact
important it's really important and now
h 5 ER this looks looks quite quite
quite okay so castling shorter so it's
not really on let's select see here rook
the end may be looking eight at some
point okay let's let's open open up the
this H file first and then see of course
my bishop is still not in the game at
mmm interesting what is he doing against
95 taking on a tool maybe maybe
but what what if I just develop like III
or queen c3 first twin c3 can Castle
long actually no this is not what i want
but i would have 95 laugh at what the
position i don't i don't know really i
don't know p for Bishop b4 night f seven
four complete craziness
okay not sure that this is any good
though yeah so how to how to turn back
now okay night f7 is not even working
you too Luke f8 and thus there's
something bad happening on f200 cook and
I could have played night takes g6 of
course this was was at least interesting
ah what what what the heck
okay that's hard to do something else
now yeah just perfectly five probably
yeah this was entirely unnecessary
relief Quincy three was just bad
probably and it was a I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure it was a very good
position hard to imagine that this
should should should have been there
should have been good for black ok I can
take now on dat it's not a maid on f 2
ok it actually isn't made so rook seat
or something play
maybe something like that protecting f2
yeah I'm not the two-wheeler down it so
it's just completely crazy John maybe
that isn't so bad actually
it's got this good let's check on you
one but it's just one check out check
time while the rukon h7s son is active
check I can actually take here check
check I know okay at least it's not not
not a complete blunder of the rook we're
just lucky
check tried to check on it I to check ok
check ok man he will manage that resigns
yeah that was a very very strange game
ok let's let's let's check this I mean
ok you can analyze this for ages here
night 27 is maybe just a win they are I
know that Jess stuff like that before
and stuff and it's not it's not not
clear very complicated stuff so I didn't
want to do that chick cause here I'm I
have a tempo h4 on an online and it
really should be good maybe I should
just play some some technical stuff here
and be better like 24 which is just just
better for a wide long term but okay
this is this is this is must be good for
white no doubt just the matter of
precision Quincy three probably was not
not really really great maybe just III
yeah that's a very difficult stuff to
play and then let's at least for me as
it is so technical v3 is probably better
my main problem was that that here III
is winning for white interesting yeah I
my problem was I over looked at f2 hangs
with three SS winning according to the
computer because of night g6 takes ciao
that's indeed hard too hard to prevent
yeah okay I had a head plenty for
beforehand and your computer wants to go
every year but that's so ugly I couldn't
I couldn't do that in this sound this is
probably just good for black queen bee
to us better
Gavin no this is this is just a key oops
oh he had to made it to ya I made entry
that's funny okay so it continues yeah
probably i should just take with the
night I wanted to be tricky him to maybe
this is maybe this is still okay i don't
know if i get you 6 now they can fight
that but it's it's struggling yeah it
had its ups and downs but the the
opening of again proof that it's very
dangerous he did simply didn't know any
of it and already found himself in a
very tricky position I mean this is
probably here and this a 33 is probably
just very good difficult to play a movie
at for black if you consider this for
example what are you doing now and white
is just just winning outright the H file
is very dangerous if you castle again
that's a double attack and they are very
very dangerous alright thanks for
watching